[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey did you ever notice how much of your
life depends on our knowledge of quantum
physics no well it does for example
smartphone hey give that back scientists
are developing a touchscreen made of
something called QTC quantum tunneling
composite inside the screen are millions
of tiny spiky particle can I please have
my phone back when you press down on the
screen the particles get close and
electrons make quantum leaps from one
spike to the next give me back my phone
you got it what about that fit stick
what about it
quantum physics inside it are millions
of tiny transistors and each one has
little metal gates that open and close
built upon a semiconductor when the gate
closes up electrons blow through and
when it opens nothing goes through so
what's constantly either open closed
open closed and that data stream is a
basis of everything computers do you go
[Music]
hey you see that traffic light did you
ever wonder what kind of science goes
into something like that no but I get it
quantum physics that's right you see
this is a controller box and inside this
box are millions of tiny transistors all
with little tiny gates that open and
close transistors flowing electrons I
understand that's right and much like
the traffic light goes from red to green
to red again telling cars to stop or go
where a transistor control the flow of
electrons you see all those commands are
encoded as ones and zeros a long string
of codes that can translate any usable
information how about that I don't care
you don't care how can you not care I
mean all day long ones and zeros are a
fabric of our technological light your
rights and I'm very grateful to you for
time not to me a lot of physics and for
everything that was everywhere think is
what it is you know what that's right
I'm gonna go to that store and I'm gonna
buy something I'm going to think about
all the ways that quantum physics has
helped me make that purchase really yes
that's great she gets it and quantum
physics is so cool
[Music]
sorry I know my wallet is in here
somewhere
ah what the I bet you don't know the
amazing science it's happening right
here right now every time I scan your
purchases I know I know I know
transistors and electrons and light
amplification of stimulated emission of
radiation
what lasers without quantum physics you
wouldn't be able to stimulate atoms
enough to have them release photons at a
specific wavelength which is what
creates that unique laser being you see
can you just scan my stuff please I can
because of quantum physics without
lasers I wouldn't be able to do this
without lasers you wouldn't have that
late 90s disc man you always carry
around know about that
without lasers this cat would miss out
on its favorite toy here that's for you
thank you now will this be cash or
credit
Oh credit I'm a little broke this strip
I know quantum physics no it's just a
magnetic strip
there's nothing quantum about it in fact
it's the same technology is this mixtape
from 1988 so you're telling me that that
mixtape would exist whether or not we'd
ever discovered quantum physics sure
what about this wristwatch of course I
missed MRI now that's quantum physics
you see your body is made of water which
contains hydrogen when we apply a
magnetic field to your body the hydrogen
protons line up with the external
three
quantum physics our first guest is
currently the professor of quantum
mechanical engineering at MIT and the
director of the WM Keck Center for
extreme quantum information theory his
research focuses on the role of
information in complex systems looking
at the quantum mechanics of living
systems economics and cosmology
please welcome Seth Lloyd next we have
one of the pioneers of quantum
cryptography currently he is a professor
of quantum physics at the mathematical
Institute of the University of Oxford
and at the National University of
Singapore he is also the director of the
Center for quantum technologies please
welcome our tor Eckert also with us
tonight is one of the team leaders at
NASA's quantum artificial intelligence
lab her work in quantum mechanics has
applications in bioinformatics robotics
and cryptography she's also the author
of the book quantum computing a gentle
introduction please welcome Elinor 3fl
and our final participant is a faculty
member specializing in quantum
information at the Perimeter Institute
in Waterloo Ontario his work with
quantum error correction as applications
in cryptography computation and quantum
teleportation please welcome Daniel
Gotha Smith
[Music]
there's no escaping it quantum mechanics
is weird
Einstein called it spooky Verner
Heisenberg wondered if nature could
possibly be so absurd even Niels Bohr a
staunch defender of quantum theory said
anyone who thinks they can talk about
quantum mechanics without getting dizzy
hasn't yet understood the first word of
it so be prepared you may get a little
lightheaded
tonight and who knows where your
thoughts may lead we're gonna take a
look at teleportation unbreakable codes
and cryptography and quantum computers
and then ask where it all might lead us
ten years from now and so first quantum
teleportation as in beam me up Scotty
[Music]
Scotty energize Scotty what's the matter
we can't make transporter contact sir
the entire systems inhibited where it is
now II couldn't beam up a fly back to
the future and almost to the present the
way it is now in 2015 we can't beam up a
fly but scientists have believe it or
not actually started beaming or
teleporting something we hear over a
distance even if miles now so assess
what exactly is being teleported in the
Star Trek depiction and what's happening
now on oh so teleportation it really is
a kind of strange Trekkie and thing so
the idea is let me take Artur maybe you
could be not Kirk but Captain Picard
[Laughter]
the idea behind teleportation is you'd
like to dematerialize Captain Picard
here and re materialize him over there
now for a long time people thought that
quantum mechanics would prevent this
from happening because when you look at
something you mess it up and so if you
have to look at something to get infor
enough information about it to teleport
it you would just not only D materialize
it but destroy it but this funky
entanglement this quantum weirdness
where things are having no things that
this far away from each other know much
more about each other than they ought to
know this actually allows you to do this
so the idea is you set up a bunch of
entangled particles you make a
measurement on Captain Picard together
with the entangled particles over here
and this generates information just a
string of bits ordinary classical bits
and you take those bits and you send
them over to Scotty over here and this
allows Scotty to ream aterial eyes
Captain Picard over there by changing
the state of the other entangled
particles he can recreate what was
destroyed over here it was just in from
he was destroyed here but he's
reconstituted just the same over there
well if everything works okay hopefully
yeah yeah that's that's right so
everything if everything works just as
you would like then then things get
reconstruct and there's nothing done
with the photons yeah so it's done the
way it's been done now and actually for
20 years now though this is not
something that that is completely new
people since the mid 1990s have been
teleporting particles of light from here
over there your pair of entangled
photons you bring in another photon make
a measurement of this photon with half
of the entangled pair send some
classical bits of information over here
monkey with this other photon and voila
it is the same and theoretically that
could happen between here and Mars or
between here and the other side the
galaxy and what speed does it happen you
have this funny feature of entanglement
that that our macroscopic intuitions
tell us that when you make the
measurement over here something happens
instantaneously over there but that's
not actually true it's more that this
quantum funkiness this is by the way a
technical one saw James Brown in concert
and and he somebody said well James
what's gonna happen next and he said I
don't know but whatever it is it's got
to be funky quantum funky so it's not
it's faster than light slower than a
dime behind no so it actually is is kind
of irrelevant it doesn't happen faster
than light but the the message you send
to reconstitute the information can go
no faster than the speed of light so you
can't recreate the thing you're
teleporting over here faster than the
speed of love until you get the
information that in hope that you put it
together the way it was when it started
it sounds dangerous so it's been done
with photons we haven't gotten to Flies
yet people could it be done yeah
theoretically you could teleport very
large things but at the moment were down
at the level of individual elementary
particles okay all right well back in
2012 the Austrian physicist Anton
Zeilinger made headlines when he
teleported photons through the
atmosphere between the two Canary
Islands about 89 miles and then last
fall in 2014 NASA and the University of
Geneva claimed a new distance record
through an optical fiber of 15 miles why
is that an important record you would
like to teleport over as long a distance
as possible and people are planning to
try to teleport from
earth up two satellites teleportation is
is a key thing to be able to do for
quantum cryptography which we're going
to hear about in a bit from our tour for
instance and they were to teleport from
earth up to a satellite you have to just
get those photons that you're sending up
there through the first bit of the
atmosphere and then you're okay why is
it important to have a record of 15
miles to a fiber-optic cable fiber optic
cables higher loss than just the after
the atmosphere so if you can do it
through fiber optics and that's also a
very useful thing if you want to do for
example send information secretly over
fiber optic cable higher loss you said
in other words it doesn't leak so much
yeah the atmosphere doesn't leak as well
you know the atmosphere doesn't leak as
much as a fiber optic cable I'm not sure
if I can say that yeah but the fiber
optic cable doesn't think as much or you
can go around corners like a fiber optic
cable yeah that's right and banks are
connected by fiber optic cables as our
agencies with three letters in their
names so art or we hear that China the
US and Europe if not competing are all
trying to figure out how to transport
beam photons into outer space what lots
of drugs not only in China Europe in the
US but quite a few working meeting sort
of quantum technology or quantum optics
that are trying to use sources of
entangled photons and put them somewhere
in the atmosphere in a satellite so that
you can beam those particles entangled
photons down to two points and why would
it be better to do that and just send a
radio signal well you would like to have
a source of entangled photons because
you can use those entangled photon later
on if you just if you can send one and
one pair one member of the pair to say
Alice and another one to Bob we use LS
and Bob all the time in our you know a
quantum jargon it's very easy to put
some humans there so Alice's there's one
physicist that it would be doing some
experiments on photons and Bob would be
another one and that would enable them
to communicate secretly for example so
that's why to have it's just convenient
to have one source somewhere up there
that anyone can tune in okay now I want
to expand a little bit I've heard some
rumors that time travel could also be
involved Seth you were talking about
this
yeah so teleportation is already pretty
wacky this is another technical term and
you might also send things into the past
so so there are in generality it's it's
possible to have closed timelike curves
where you follow some path through space
and you end up seeing the spaceship over
there and that spaceship is your
spaceship in the past so this is allowed
and Einstein's theory of general
relativity one of the prevailing
theories of how this works quantum
mechanically is that it's just like
teleportation but teleportation to the
past so it's teleportation but now you
don't have to send these signals these
classical signals at the speed of light
you can actually set up an entangled
state here in an entangled state there
and the result is that the spaceship
that enters this closed timelike curve
then exits it in the past it has
teleported to the past how do you decide
if it's safe to do that well it's not
very safe though we actually we found
once my colleagues and I came up with a
serum n tling so with EEPROM steinberg
at the University of Toronto we did an
experiment which was the moral
equivalent of taking a photon
teleporting at about a few billionths of
a second in the past and of course we
had to try to kill its former self how'd
that go well you know those movies were
at the end they say that no animals were
harmed during the making of this movie
it just wasn't like that with photons in
our experiment many of them died but the
one that the one photon that made it
back in the past and tried to kill
itself failed ok I get it
I think I get it I don't understand it
but I get it I'm beginning to feel like
a like a quantum particle that is both
dead and alive does get it and doesn't
understand it would you like to
volunteer for the first human no no no
no
so one last note I have here is to ask
you what is post selection what might be
the practical uses of this time Carol
well let me give the other example for
how this might work so if you have a
black hole let's say and you're falling
to a black hole and you'd like to escape
from this them the way a black hole
works it sucks in all the stuff around
you fall in you have a very brief period
of time to say your prayers and then you
hit this singularity where everything
goes away like that like that and and we
don't know what happens at the
singularity which is you might think
that that's a problem but if you're a
theorist like me it's actually an
opportunity so and so if the idea is
that this what happens is the black hole
is like making a measurement but it's a
measurement that always gives the same
result and that allows what falls into
the black hole effectively to teleport
out of the black hole and thereby be
saved I think that in your Captain
Picard incarnation that you did this in
one Star Trek episode any practical uses
for this here on earth before we get out
there to the black holes well you know
we our experiment we didn't actually
take black holes we asked MIT if we were
allowed to make small black holes in the
laboratory and the workplace safety
people forbid us from doing everything
standing in the way of science it's
terrible but the earth might have been
sucked in I can understand the problem
all right so I get it and I don't
understand it exactly but we're getting
there
and maybe this is another good human
subject experiment you might want to
volunteer for you guys so so let's now
move to cryptography and unbreakable
codes Archer this has been a specialty
of yours to protect our most sensitive
secret first of all tell us how our
secrets are protected in the pre quantum
way of keeping secrets banks for example
our data of course many ways of doing it
one way that is quite popular is to use
a certain mathematical difficulty over
certain problems as a as a safety
feature it's probably the best way to
explain it is the notion of public key
cryptosystem that I use a lot is to to
think about a mechanical analogy so
imagine for example that you have
a mechanical dog so so I had a safe box
with two keyholes and two keys so one
key is good for locking the box and
another key is good for unlocking the
box now I can distribute those safe
boxes to anyone who wants to communicate
with me they are open and then you will
have this locking key which is known as
a public key attached to the safe box so
now if you want to send a message to me
you'll simply write a message put it
into the box and lock it now once you
lock it you cannot use the same key to
unlock the box it just is just a locking
key a public key the locking key and in
order to unlock the box I have to use my
private key unlocking key so the box
comes to me and then just use the
private key that stays with me and this
way I can unlock the box and look at the
message and read the message so now of
course the the safe box is a certain
mathematical procedure and the two
mechanical keys are in fact two strings
of numbers and and that is a very clever
system as a beautiful mathematical
invention and it's really it's really
beautiful the problem is that once you
may ask you know once I have this public
key the locking key and I know how the
device works is it possible for me to
figure out the private key so is there a
way for me to construct the unlocking
key and the answer is well basically yes
but it's extremely complicated and the
safety is based on the fact that it is
extremely complicated
that if I if I give you my public key
you can look at it and you would have to
perform a very complicated computation
in order to reconstruct my private key
and break the code however however you
know that with quantum computers that
that may come so they so this whole
system would collapse if quantum
computers came well yes so that not only
it was a few few possible scenarios you
know the computer science is working in
the area called computational complexity
even today that they are not they divide
these problems into easy problems more
difficult problems very difficult
problem extremely difficult problems and
and the mathematical problem that is
behind the method that I just mentioned
is base
factoring large integers and then even
classical camino even classical
computers may be able to do it we simply
don't know we are just in a position
when you ask me can you solve factoring
problem in a reasonable time I say I
cannot I can you know point to many
colleagues that they cannot either but
we don't know we cannot prove it's
impossible
so how would quantum code be able to be
unbreakable and does it it involves
entanglement somehow right right so it's
about that what we can do we are talking
about quantum entanglement do particles
for example two photons can be placed in
different locations and other one can go
to say Alice another one can go to Bob
hell is involved then we'll interrogate
photo so they perform measurements on
those filters and they respond in such a
way that whenever Alice register bit
value zero Bob will register bit value 0
and so on so forth but the basic idea is
that if you interrogate entangled
photons in two different locations the
two people who do that they will end up
with a string of identical and random
numbers and then you can use those
random numbers later on for secret
communication now the interesting thing
is that if there is an eavesdropper on
the line so if if it is indeed the case
that somewhere in between the source of
entangled photon and Alice and Bob there
is the enemy trying to eavesdrop and tap
on this by doing so the eavesdropper is
going to introduce certain errors and
Alice and Bob by running a very simple
statistical test will be able to find
out that there was indeed an
eavesdropper on the line so this way
they will not they know that there is an
eavesdrop and therefore they will try to
repeat this but it's called technically
key distribution scheme over and over
again because they'll see that there
were some errors yeah it shouldn't be
there so there must have been somebody
sneaking yes right so there's a simple
statistical test that tells you that
someone is there on the line so the
purpose of eavesdropping is not to to
prevent Alice and Bob from communicating
or distributing this key is to just
fool them so they think that there's no
one there and eavesdroppers sort of
hiding its presence and and knows the
secret that was distributed to Alice and
Bob do you think it'll ever become the
case in the future that you can invent
some ways to eavesdrop undetected that's
the point in the whole story of
cryptography there was always sort of a
battle between code makers and code
breaker whenever people came up with a
very clever ways of encrypting something
sooner or later someone would come with
even more clever and more beautiful way
of decrypting it or breaking the code in
this particular case we believe that the
notion of security is somewhat different
it's just relies on the laws of physics
and I let me just venture let me just
make this statement I think that that
that the quantum cryptography and all
these entanglement base crypto systems
will probably be unbreakable if
implemented properly so there will be no
way of eavesdropping on the system
because any act of eavesdropping will be
then detected Edgar Allen Poe famously
said any code made by humans can be
broken by humans yeah look what happened
here
he died mysteriously at the age of 40
maybe there was a quantum going on well
as far as I know he he had a right to
say what he said simply because at that
time it was certainly the case if you
look at the history of cryptography and
the history of making ciphers that was
certainly the case that I don't I think
the way the quantum physics the rules of
the game are somewhat different the
security is not based on mathematical
difficulty on ingenuity is based on the
laws of physics so it's like a lot of
quantum physics quantum physics physics
you know the laws of physics as
formulated today formulated in the
language of quantum mechanics which and
all these weird qualities we talked
about that we've learned about allow
this perpetual access to something can
always be random and therefore private
in that moment correct so interestingly
enough what dimensional randomness is
related to the notion of security and
but it's somewhat different and quantum
physics allows you also to construct
devices that truly generate truly random
numbers that you can not only in the
sense that they are uniformly
distributed but also truly unpredictable
but any other entity and so so that that
has some bearing on cryptography but
also on many other areas
so now let's Eleanor and Dan let's move
along to quantum computers many
professions have been for some thirty
years saying with great hype and a lot
of struggle that they can't wait to get
a hold of quantum computers whatever
they are but you haven't really much
listened to this we just know they've
been saying quantum computers are going
to change the world they're going to
expand our ability to compute everything
but they haven't happened yet Eleanor we
have a picture here of a quantum device
we understand you all are beginning to
get kind of close a quantum device that
you're working on at NASA Ames Research
Center your lab your lab works in
collaboration with Google who has
provided this image there's somebody
that works on a micro scale this has
some big parts to it tell us what we're
looking at here describe what we're
seeing it's not exactly an iPhone so
you're mostly seeing the dilution
refrigerator part of the quantum
annealing device that d-wave built
quantum annealing quantum annealing all
right and this is keeping a cold and
that's keeping it cold and what you're
now seeing is the chip which is really
what does all the work everything else
was just trying to keep it really really
cold to keep it from dqo hearing so what
is it so this is this is a quantum
computer chip and I understand it uses
superposition that idea that something
can be in two states or two places at
once that's right us how superposition
really makes computer chip much more
powerful well first I'll just explain
that these are superconducting qubits in
this case the zeros and ones correspond
to flow going around in a clockwise
direction or a counter clockwise
direction and just so that you enjoy
this as much as possible it can do both
at once it can do both of ones right
which with the normal computer it's
either a 1 or a 0
that's right I still get it only does
this if it's really cold if it only does
if it's really cold and nobody's looking
at it and nobody's looking at it right
I'm sorry I've just got to stop here and
ask how does it know we're looking at
before I know it's a silly question but
it isn't a silly question and one of the
things we're trying very very very hard
to do in this whole field is to make
sure that nobody looks at it except when
when we're trying to look at a very
specific part to do like error
correction that Daniel will be talking
about in a bit oh okay so so some how
can I explain it absolutely quantum
computing is the opposite of pornography
we only know it when we don't see it I
feel more like a quantum particle than
ever I get it and I don't understand a
word of it but I get it thank you very
much the helpful metaphor borrowed from
the Supreme Court Potter Stewart Potter
Stewart so the fact that something
holding information can hold it as a 1
and a 0 at the same time which I don't
understand but I get it but I don't
understand it means you have many more
possibilities you can look at all at
once while you're sending information
around that's right and also if you have
entanglement you have correlations that
you can't see classically and those are
also useful for computation what kind of
correlate what you said annealing what
is that ah so annealing you have both
classical and quantum versions of that
and there's also physical versions and
then we imitate it computationally to do
optimization problems so that sounds
great I'm not sure what are you so one
thing that's important here is to
understand that that chip is doing one
particular type of quantum computation
not general quantum computation and we
also have classical computers that can
do annealing that follow basically the
trajectory we're seeing here where
they're trying to find the lowest point
in a landscape so we're they're trying
to minimize a cost function for example
for a problem
we want to find the minimum cost of
something if you just take the naive
approach of climbing downhill as fast as
possible and then get stuck because
you're not willing to climb back uphill
you can get in a low point but it's
often not the lowest point so there's an
annealing where you carefully control
what's called the temperature which
tells you how much how frequently you'll
be willing to go uphill and so when the
temperatures warm you're willing to go
uphill a lot and as things cool down
you'll tend to stay in those minimum and
to be clear the the you that is willing
to go up or down hill are photons they
can be they can be photons or bits and
you kind of have ways of come track of
them to see what yeah so they're really
they're really states of a whole bunch
of bits or qubits just to be clear a
qubit is a quantum bit is that right Q u
bi T that's right all right right and
and tunneling what is that so instead of
so you know in classical case when you
get stuck in one of these minima the
only thing you can do is climb back out
in the quantum case you have tunneling
available to you where you can with some
probability go through a barrier and
this can be very very useful if for
example you want to get to a minimum on
the other side of a very narrow barrier
that might be very very hard to climb
out of but relatively easy to tunnel
forgive here that's with some
probability you may be able to go
through a barrier if I get up and walk
into that wall the probability is a
hundred percent I'm not gonna go so it
isn't it isn't no you mean there's a
probability that I could walk oh yes
it's another human subject experiment
do not sign me up point zero zero zero
zero zero one probably a lot of ways
you're actually one so all my all my
events that's very very small and all my
atoms would go through all the atoms
there and it could happen and we don't
have enough time for you to try it that
many times but we value your presence
all right so that's what tunneling is
and you can get a probability for this
tunneling and how do you use that well
if you want to find the lowest-cost of
something and you're trying to explore
this cost landscape then you might get
stuck in a place which looks like it's
the lowest because everything you can
see around it is higher but there might
be something that's really nearby that's
lower and you classically would have to
climb all the way out of that in order
to see and go into the lower part but in
quantum mechanics you can just tunnel
through and get to the lower ah you're
serious that you've been having this and
you and this machine you have you've
already been doing this well there have
been some experiments that have shown
that with high likelihood tunnelling is
going on in this machine why do I say
high likelihood I don't know because
it's really hard to see what's going on
without messing things up and if you
that's right because as we've learned
three before if some if you look at it
it's gonna stop doing right does is a
quantum thing so one of the really
tricky things here is to probe a system
well enough to understand what's going
on without messing things up okay
alright so now now Daniel we're coming
to your specialty it's hard to make
these systems that owners working with
here error free but you've got some
specialty you've been working on and
I've been noted for figuring out how to
solve the error problem right so we'd
like to build these big quantum
computers or teleport quantum states
from here to Texas or to Mars or you
know create quantum cryptography devices
but the problem is that the machines
that we build they're never going to be
absolutely perfect and in fact quantum
systems are particularly delicate
because as we've said so many times you
know if you look at it that's enough to
cause an error and it doesn't have to be
a person looking at it again it could be
just a single atom that happens
be passing by and decides to take a
little peek so if you want to build one
of these big quantum computers or long
distance teleportation or anything like
that
the the likelihood of being able to
complete the whole thing without any
errors is incredibly small so what we
need is we need some way of protecting
the system against errors and correcting
them and you've figured something out we
have a technique called quantum error
correcting codes and fault-tolerant
quantum computation and the idea there
is we take the the quantum information
that normally would reside on a single
qubit quantum bit and spread it out
among multiple qubits so that there's
some redundancy and then if one of them
has an error then we can kind of look at
the relationships between these
different qubits and see that there's an
error there and indeed we can even
figure out what it is and correct it so
the quantum computer becomes much more
active relatively accurate that's right
so even though you're gonna have this
big quantum computer errors are
occurring all the time we're correcting
them and at the end of the day when you
finish your computation you get the
right answer that sounds like a lot of
heavy lifting it is in fact there are
lots of estimates for for how much how
many more quantum bits you need to build
a fault-tolerant quantum computer than a
regular quantum computer and it could be
you know a factor of a hundred or a
thousand times as much but the thing is
that without that factor of a hundred or
a thousand you don't have a quantum
computer at all and I understand you use
teleportation in India so how explain
how you use teleportation in doing this
so so so quantum teleportation is kind
of this very helpful trick so earlier we
talked about using it to move qubits or
other things very long distances but
it's also useful if you want to move
quantum states for very short distances
and you can create this entangled state
and if you make it a the correct kind of
entangled State when you teleport the
system you can actually make it come out
different at the end and do a
computation on it by teleporting it how
well well we mentioned
you the fly before so maybe that can
give you some idea of what could happen
that's right
the one with Jeff Goldblum well that's
right so you teleport from A to B and he
comes out he's kind of mixed up with the
DNA of a fly of course in reality it
doesn't work quite that way but we can
make something similar happen with
individual quantum states why are you
but it's but it's for good and not for
evil Seth you're smiling knowingly the
character in the flyer gets teleported
it's named Seth so give us give us a
sense you're both working on these two
these quantum computers why why are so
many people so excited who don't even
really fully understand what quantum
computers are above the advent the
possible advent of quantum computers
what will they be able to do that we
can't do now is it gonna be many
magnitudes of order of magnitudes
greater so we have a few algorithms like
factoring where we know that the quantum
algorithms we have are better than
anything we have classically and have a
major effect on practical things like
encryption
there are also algorithms for for
example quantum simulation but there is
a huge array of problems for which we
don't know whether there are quantum
algorithms that can help or not but yes
so classically there are many many
places where we are looking for better
and better algorithms and how we decide
whether an algorithm is better is by
running it on a computer and comparing
the results to previous examples and
seeing whether that algorithm
outperforms what we've seen before
what kind of real-world application so
for example optimization problems of
various sorts there are many many
different approaches to doing
optimization what's an optimization
problem so this is a place where you're
trying to find for example the minimum
of minimal cost minimal energy where you
have resources that you're trying to
preserve
a minimal amount of gunpowder you need
to use sure sure minimal amount of food
you can live on for a certain month
minimum amount of food that the world
could live on yeah or the minimal amount
of energy that we could create without
mechanical warming worse or the minimal
trip you can make to the next few places
you need to go as a journalist and the
distance you go might be quite different
from the cost given how the airplanes
their lines decide costs the world gets
more and more globalized more like a
unified system which is happening fairly
rapidly it's looking at an enormous
amount of davida that a quantum computer
could possibly get its arms around so to
speak well this is a huge unknown and
that's one of the things we're really
interested in looking at is whether
there are possibilities for example in
optimization for quantum computers to
outperform what we're able to do
classically and in the classical case in
many cases we aren't able to prove that
the current classical algorithm we have
is the best and in fact we often find
something a little later that does
better in the quantum case we haven't
even been able to run them on machines
until really recently and so that's one
of the really exciting things in the
next decades is to be able to run on
increasingly complex quantum computing
devices and before we go on Daniel how
soon do you think you're going to be
able to help these content computers get
accurate enough to do some of these
things well I do get asked this question
a lot and I usually say 20 or 30 years
on the basis that by then you'll have
forgotten what I said but you have a
sort of a gut feeling about that well I
think it will happen progress I mean
it's very difficult to build these big
quantum computers in order to get the
error correction working first of all
you need a lot of qubits as I told you
before but you also need the error rates
to be very low so that errors don't
build up faster than you can correct
them and it's it's really difficult to
work with you know single atoms are
really tiny superconducting loops and
and make them that accurate and the
machinery that you scientists use to do
this
are things like we're seeing up here
there they got dials and knobs and yeah
well usually there's something very very
very small like in this case a small
computer chip that's extra with
superconducting circuits and then a lot
of big control machinery and
refrigeration and stuff like that that
goes around it so it you're at the
beginning of it and it has an enormous
promise for us humans being able to
control a world that we can now all look
at simultaneously on the world wide web
and the internet which means that we're
all receiving much more information than
we know what to do with anyway yeah just
don't look at it too closely all right
well it sounds like you may be offering
us a kind of a new artificial brain with
which to manage some of this enormous
influx of information which the Internet
is now bringing to all of us and driving
some of us nuts with because we are
learning much more than we know what to
do with well we don't we don't really
know actually and one of the most
exciting things about quantum
computation is that it's different from
the computers we have now I mean we're
used to having new computers come out
all the time they're faster of course
and the thing is that those computers
they do the same thing it's just they do
it faster and if you have a Mac or PC
they do the same thing right they can
run the same programs
somebody has to translate it from you
know Mac operating system to PC
operating system or vice versa but
quantum computers are different you
can't take a program that runs on a
quantum computer and translate it to run
on a regular computer you can't you
cannot it just has new rules new things
that the quantum computer can do but the
classical computer cannot do and so what
that means is that there going to be
some problems like factoring large
numbers or simulating quantum systems
that we know that a quantum computer is
or we're pretty sure that a quantum
computer is much much better at regular
classical computer but there's probably
other problems where it doesn't give any
event any advantage at all and so one of
the things as researchers that we try to
do is figure out exactly what the point
of computer is good for you know what
it's not good for there is there's some
limited results on that but nothing
really definite we're probably not going
to be running Microsoft Word on a clock
sir and Artur what about your
cryptography hopes well quantum
computers fulfill what you want to have
happen
quantum computers can take away
classical security so quantum mechanics
takes away something from from our
classical notion of security but it can
give back
it can give quantum cryptography so
certainly having quantum computers would
be quite a good incentive to work and
focus on developing quantum cryptography
further even though it's is it's the
most advanced part of quantum technology
you can purchase quantum key
distribution systems today you can yes
unlike quantum computers which are much
more sophisticated and require lots of
extra things to stabilize them as Daniel
motion you can purchase quantum
cryptography yeah so the quantum
cryptography is the few companies you
can go on internet and checks and say ID
Quantic one of them in Switzerland and
few others and what you can do basically
you can you can set up quantum
cryptography between two points so that
you can distribute those random numbers
the cryptographic key between two
different locations so that that is
practical now but that's the simplest
thing because just like one quantum
operation doesn't even have to be
protected that much up to a point
so it's already here I don't think
Walmart is selling them yet though no no
radio chatter no it's so they're not on
sale yet except in these specialized
places well yeah you can you can I'm
sure you can purchase them but but and
but you know that kind of technology
even though it requires some improvement
is relatively easy as compared to
quantum computing quantum computing is a
device where you have a number of
quantum logic gates quantum operations
performing a certain way and you want to
have them coherent and you want to have
them stabilized so that's that's much
more much more difficult but but but the
good thing is that the part of quantum
technology is here it's already it is a
beginning reality's beginning all right
so
to move them we're now beginning to live
with lots of quantum information
technology around us it's been here
longer than most of us have realized
it's here and with the work you're all
doing and teleportation in cryptography
and computing it sounds like we may be
in for even more mind-boggling changing
changes coming up I mean I get the sense
here though I don't fully understand it
of course I get the sense here that
you're talking about the beginning of a
whole new way of information being
passed around that pretty soon we'll all
be taking for granted even if we don't
understand it
but let's take a step further imagine
that you could teleport us all that you
could teleport all of us here ten years
into the future into 2025 say well my
goodness look there there we all are
people are waving from back from 2025
the audience has been teleported into
2025 so what new powers might quantum
information technology have by Zen
Eleanor what new computational power
might NASA have under its belt by 2025
when this audience was there now what
might but we expect to have some bigger
and more robust machines to play with
and in that process we very much hope
that we'll have a clearer idea of where
the really key applications for quantum
computing are in the future in other
words it's like Cortes looking at the at
the Pacific it's big you don't quite
know what's over there yet yeah so we
don't know where the really good islands
are to go for and we don't know how big
they are but it promises to be able to
grapple with global scales of
information that's right Wow assess you
10 years ago that is today made a
comment about how quantum information
may in fact revolutionize medicine with
something you were referring to as
Global genomic database how how would
that in 2025 if such a thing could
happen tell us what it is and how it
could make the world healthier yeah so
so in the past 10 years we have
developed quantum computers with
hundreds of qubits of quantum bits that
we can manipulate over tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of operations
actually this is speaking from today
this is actually what this is what's
projected by the people who build such
systems and one application that Daniel
and Eleanor failed to mention 10 years
ago is processing data which you were
alluding to so processing very very
large amounts of data machine learning
is is all the rage these days because by
not only from Google and Facebook but
also letters with three agencies and
their names they wish to find out all
kinds of patterns and large amounts of
data and if you can encode that data in
a quantum mechanical state and then
manipulate it using an even a quite
small scale quantum computer which might
not even require much quantum error
correction then you could actually find
patterns which you could not find with
an ordinary quantum computer as an
example let's take a hypothetical
database which is a database that
contains the information about all the
genomes of all the human beings on earth
all the genomes of all the humans on
earth doable in the future yeah I mean
yeah absolutely I mean actually this is
this is data that could be collectives a
lot of data it's it's on the order of
ten to the twenty bits I think which is
a little less than all the data that's
ever been collected by human being so
far but the amount of data that we're
collecting is doubling every year or so
so it's a gigantic database and you'd
like to find patterns in in these in
these genes in order to help people you
know who might have genetic diseases
a genetic a complete genetic picture of
all seven billion of us that could have
enormous medical implications right and
also privacy issues as well I'm not sure
I want my insurance company knowing
what's in my genome are you gonna
prevent it yeah so so one of the great
so if you encode this in a quantum
mechanical form you could encode this
gigantic database in about 60 quantum
bits
and in these 60 quantum bits you
couldn't store all the information in
this database and then process it to
reveal information that might you know
help people find the presence of genetic
diseases try to find patterns that exist
among people from different from the
same population or from similar families
and the nice thing about is that you can
combine it with these quantum
cryptographic methods to ensure that the
data remains secret from at least my
insurance company that that's a problem
but before we get to the problem what an
astonishing boon that would be for the
human race I mean Edward o Wilson bee
biologist has been pleading with us for
decades to understand ourselves as a
species for own good this would give us
a glimpse of ourselves as a species they
could have a normal even psychological
information as well not just biological
information yeah well next you if you
wanted to store the information in
everybody's brain that would be a bigger
database actually it turns out that if
you the whole universe as a database or
a computer then they're about 2 to the
300 elementary particles and in the
universe which you could then encode
into 300 quantum bits so why stop with
human beings let's go for the Guster but
I get all those 60 cubits on my cell
phone on a little chip yeah you mean so
you could we could have a quantum app or
a crap it raises enormous questions
about what the possibilities would be
but always when we have new technologies
in our species we also present new
possibilities of great abuse what are
the great possible abuses of something
like this I don't even want to think
about it right well that's why I think
that indeed if one were to collect such
a database and and I don't think that in
ten years we will have such a database
but we could easily have such a database
in 20 or 30 years then you would want to
have some privacy and and it's when you
combine when you take relatively small
quantum computers of the kind that are
in this trope we already have it being
10 years down the line and you combine
these with with questions like with
techniques borrowed from quantum
cryptography you get much greater rights
for having information processing with
your processing with your own personal
privacy built-in
Wow all right Daniel you suggested that
quantum computers might help scientists
solve some of the mysteries of quantum
mysteries that's right how the quantum
mechanics part of the reason it seems so
strange to us is that we are these giant
things made of you know 10 to the 25
atoms or something and so what's going
on at the quantum world is really very
alien to us but if you have a lot of
time to play with quantum stuff through
a quantum computer or just even thinking
about quantum computation you started to
get used to this weird behavior and get
a better intuition for how it behaves
and so now that we've had these 10 years
of development of quantum computers
we've have that much more time to kind
of get used to them and see how they
really work and I you know I hope that
once we get the price down a little bit
and little kids can have quantum
computer games that will have people
growing up and they just think quantum
mechanics is totally normal but to go
back to the first half of the question
the quantum computer could be looking
and affected itself to help explain all
the quantum weirdness that you all have
described to us the point is that if you
want to try to simulate a quantum system
so you know when we build a bridge for
instance you put it on a computer you
see how it's gonna behave before you
actually build it so if you want to do
the same thing with a molecule well you
should put it on a quantum computer to
see how it's going to behave it's too
hard to do it on a regular classical
computer but a quantum computer could do
this and so that's another way we can
kind of get more understanding of the
way the quantum world be it sounds like
we're going to get a super brain on our
hands is it going to achieve
consciousness will it be like Hal 9000
and have all of the human paranoia's
built in from the movie 2001 is that a
danger well I am not particularly
worried about it we have we have no we
have no real reason to believe that
quantum mechanics is important in
intelligence some people think that it
is I'm not one of those people all right
but he said it's not it's not it's not
Conti I'm interested to take a poll
it's kind
it's gonna be achievable in a machine
because of quantum computing coming
along well no no no no we're not a very
exciting panel on the contrary it might
have been already in classical
computation but the quantum computation
probably won't help much you look look
consciousness is weird and strange
quantum mechanics is weird and strange
but they're not weird and strange in the
same way they're not even really okay
all right all right so one more look at
the future Arthur you said it's
impossible to predict what's gonna come
so what do you hope will come in by the
year 2025 well as a scientist I I think
that that may sound a little bit
paradoxical what I'm going to say now
but I think I would like us to fail
building quantum computer for some
really good reason why well because then
we would learn something very profound
about nature it's it's like think about
quantum computing building quantum
computers ongoing experiment and and the
way we progress with our knowledge about
nature is that we make conjectures how
nature work and set up experiments and
look for reputations and and I think for
me as a scientist and most that the most
beautiful outcome of this program of
building quantum computer would be a
spectacular failure for a good reason a
fundamental reason that there is
something that we discover about the
nature it doesn't mean the end of
beautiful technology because there will
be a post quantum computing you can use
this new discoveries to make even more
beautiful more powerful encryption
system perhaps computers so so I think
for engineers it's is a great idea and a
great challenge to build a quantum
computer for a scientist interested in
foundations of physics or fundamental
principle of nature I think much more
interesting scenario is a spectacular
failure often is we usually learn from
mistakes at this point I want to ask for
the iPad to be brought forward that's
going to have a few questions on it from
around the world of the Internet thank
you very much but it sounds like you all
are on the trail of a way to
help us control all the information
that's coming up all right so Gemma V
via Twitter from New Jersey asks is it
possible to have more than two particles
entangled together if so could you send
objects to more than one place yeah the
answer is affirmative yes you can
how many well as many as you can you can
untangle as many particles as you can so
you could it could be well you can
tangle thread to is the most common but
of course you know you can have three of
them in the highly entangled state and
you can send them to three different
locations they would be maybe entangle
in somewhat different way there's like
one way of entangling two particles but
I should say that if you actually try to
teleport a quantum state to these
different locations it doesn't end up
one here and one here and one here
instead ends up spread out and kind of
again entangled between these multiple
different locations you all agreed what
he just said yeah it comes from the
no-cloning theorem of quantum mechanics
how does that work
it says you can't clone a quantum it
means you can't take you can't you can't
take an unknown state you can take it
under something that state and you can
move it teleporter from here to there
but you can't teleport two copies to one
place and to another Sun like Star Trek
with the good and evil Kirk well
actually maybe it is bit like that they
get messed up if you try to clone them
so remember and said I was trying to
tell her told me from here today he
would have to destroy me here in order
for me to be reconstructed there I
cannot just be clone I can be teleported
but that's different so it wouldn't be
you being teleported it would be you
being rebuilt that's right and only one
copy because Artur is unique I believe
so yes only one copy and yet you could
have three entangled or four or five
entangled I have no idea what I'm
talking about
so it's a fun game to play there are
different questions right so then one is
can you and tango nparticles were all
certain 42 particles yes the answer is
you can but when you ask another
questions like take a quantum objects
how many copies of this quantum objects
can you make then we answered well do
you have a problem here because you
cannot make identical copies of a
quantum object that is in a state that
you don't know what it is so there's
lots and lots of different kinds of
entanglement and the type that we're
talking about earlier between two
particles that's kind of the simplest
kind of entanglement when you start to
bring in more and more particles than
you get into all these other weird zoo
of different kinds of entanglement and
it becomes honestly much too complicated
even for for for me
and for any of us for any of us really I
mean we don't have a full understanding
of all the different types of
entanglement but if you had one of these
hoped for
big full-scale quantum computers they
might be able to handle it yeah that
would be very nice use of a quantum
computer would be to study the uses of
entanglement okay it does give you a
headache this - I mean Niels Bohr was
right you do have to get dizzy to begin
done do you guys have this experience
yourselves well one of the really nice
things is that we have a tool for
talking about this and thinking about
this that we haven't had available up
here so much which is the language of
mathematics and a lot of this becomes
much clearer when you can write down
these equations and they may look very
strange when you first look at them but
then things become much clearer and
that's how we know how to work with
these things
ah but even after you've been working
for it with quantum mechanics for years
sometimes it can really surprise you
yeah and you'll get a little dizzy
anyway yeah which is a sign of your
getting somewhere necessary but not
sufficient
I'd like to before we finish up here
we're running out of time go back to one
question before that has been left
dangling if that happens in the quantum
universe from before where you talked
about the fact that it doesn't matter
how far away an entangled part of
is from the first one the transportation
can be made but you have to also get
information over to that other one so it
knows how to reconstruct what's happened
and that it has to be done by the slower
than light means correct that's right
couldn't have said it better myself
you're right yeah yeah yeah yeah
perfectly right but I don't understand
what I just said
[Laughter]
and yet because of Einstein's space-time
curves it may be possible to do it
across a galaxy in something less than a
bazillion years well so if you had these
closed timelike curves or you had a
couple of rapidly rotating black holes
then maybe just maybe you have a chance
of jumping in here and instantaneously
reappearing somewhere else but I
wouldn't put my bets on it so there's
going to be an hour exam next Thursday
on black holes and their quantum nature
listen my head hurts I get it
I have no idea what's going on but it's
really very exciting I'd like to to let
you all know the good news that our
wonderful guests have told us that they
will be very happy to meet you out in
the lobby after they are liberated from
their microphones if you have further
questions I can't imagine there be any
further questions let's give them all a
hand and we hope you had a great time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]